uh but uh not an easy year to be a
receiver
no kenny galladay not a whole lot of
action yeah
expected to visit the giants has an
offer from the bengals well it must not
be a great offer he would have taken it
you know this is a guy who i think had
had designs on 20 million a year maybe
more
this isn't the year number one for cap
reasons to get it number two with all
these great young receivers how can you
justify how can you justify putting that
much money in a guy who didn't play much
at all last year that's right just draft
a receiver and uh chances are
better than 50
50 that you're going to get a guy that
can come in and play yeah no mike i mean
i think you're right there like when you
just evaluate the situation and you said
this last week you know the salary cap
forget that it's lower than it was last
year it's about what teams expected it
to be in this year and what was the
number you threw out there that it
really is 208 yeah wait right it's like
so 25 million dollars less than where
teams expected to be in 2010. i think
that's why you see you know gallaudet
still out there juju smith schuster
because they're going by the old market
going wait wait these guys signed for
this last year in the off season i'm the
same type of player or better shouldn't
i get a little bit more and no that's
not going to be the case at 182.5 as far
as the salary cap's concerned and then
the other mike you're you're spot on the
other aspect is that
you know we're starting to see the draft
it the receivers are they're they're
growing on trees right now i mean we saw
a lot of talented second and third round
guys contribute to their football teams
last year i mean just think of chase
claypool and dk metcalf the last two
years the best two young receivers of
the game they were drafted late in the
second round so you know there there is
and you know i've evaluated the
receivers i probably watched somewhere
between 20 and 25 of them right now you
know there's there's six seven guys that
are first round type of talents right
there so that hurts the market as well
and uh we'll see gallaudet would be a
great addition to that team to go with
slayton ingram and and saquon barkley
wow you're putting daniel jones in a
position to succeed with that uh i would
be excited as a giants and to have
gallaudet there but it's got to be the
right price
yeah when i'm not dealing with a jets
fan in my ear producing the show i'm
dealing with a giants fan in my ear
producing
wants to know if if kenny gallaudet is a
must sign for the giants in your opinion
i don't know if he's a must sign i don't
look at it and go oh man like gosh if
they don't get him they need another
presence in the wide receiver room they
do i will say that i'm not saying it's
kenny gallaudet i like kenny galladay
because he's big plays and yet he's
lunch pail guy too he'll catch a slant
over the middle and break a tackle and
get 15 more yards but he also will run
by or catch a 50 50 ball 55 yards down
the field and make a highlight play too
that's where he's awesome he's a little
bit of a difference maker that way and
he's got you know
all aspects of the game are really good
it's hard to find a weakness the big
weakness is like what you talked about
you know it's a year where money's short
and you know receivers there's a lot of
them
also and then he played six games that's
gonna scare the crap out of people i
mean it's it's yes he's a receiver he
had injuries you know they can be
finicky athletes at times too but i do
think the giants need
another
you know legit presence over there
whether that's somebody else in free
agency or the draft they got to get that
done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports